il ya des mesures qui s'applique
aujourd'hui encore dans notre pays elles
sont levé progressivement à l'école
primaire nous allons passer du niveau 3
au niveau 2 les concerts debout et la
consommation debout dans les bars pour
en reprendre qu'en tant de règles du
quotidien vont évoluer positivement pour
nos enfants et je m'en réjouis les
discothèques pourront rouvrir depuis
décembre le nombre de cas de covile 19
explose en france et partout dans le
monde pour autant les protocoles
sanitaires ne cesse de s'alléger malgré
une tendance à la baisse depuis fin
janvier on a d'un côté des
contaminations record et de l'autre une
mortalité et une tension des services de
réanimation à la baisse
le coc u19 est il finalement encore de
maladies dangereuses avec l'arrivée de
micron le sar skov 2 n'est-il devenu
qu'une grippe contente d'y voir plus
clair dans facture
[Musique]
en france environ 20 millions 500 mille
cas de kobe 19 ont été comptabilisés
depuis le début de la crise pour plus de
cent trente et un mille morts soit un
taux de mortalité de 0 63 % à l'échelle
mondiale si on prend les mêmes
indicateurs le taux de mortalité est de
1 43% avec l'arrivée de micron ce
pourcentage c'est faux depuis le premier
cas dans le monde le 24 novembre dernier
on compte près de 600 5000 décès pour
135 millions de cas soit 0 point 44 % de
morts en france le premier cas apparaît
le 2 décembre entre cette date et le 9
février le taux de mortalité est de 0 1%
soit le même taux de mortalité que la
grippe pour autant le premier ministre
la sueur je vous le dis clairement même
atténuées ce virus n'a rien d'anodin il
ne s'agit absolument pas d'une simple
grippe le problème de ce virus ce n'est
pas tant sa létalité entente est que ça
super contagiosité d'autant que pour le
journaliste difficile d'évaluer les
chiffres de la mortalité dans celle des
15 35 ans a par exemple baissé en 2020
grâce au confinement quand on vit pas on
ne meurt pas et qu'il est possible que
la mortalité liée au corps 19 soit
contre balancer dans les années à venir
le coc ville prévoit aussi un effet
moisson c'est à dire tuer les personnes
les plus fragiles qui serait morte dans
les mois ou dans les années lire c'est
exactement ce qu'on avait vu en 2003 que
la canicule donc ce qui amène un pic de
mortalité moment là on est plus que sur
un piton et une longue bosse et jamais
vraiment descendu depuis plus d'un an
maintenant même si cet été un petit
creux mais est-ce que sur cette bo sera
compensée dans les années à venir par
une baisse de la mortalité pour
retourner la normalité ici 5 6 ans
peut-être sept dans un entretien accordé
le 19 décembre à cnn le docteur john
athènes renner professeur de médecine à
l'université george washington aux etats
unis affirmait d'ailleurs que au micro
et le virus le plus contagieux jamais
connu c'est peut-être le virus le plus
contagieux auxquels notre civilisation a
été confronté à ce qu'on a moins
d'autant plus de gens sont contaminés et
donc plus de gens vont mourir on mesure
pas non plus selon le voeu de
dangerosité d'une maladie en termes de
mortalité le les conséquences sur le
moyen terme selon terme pouvait être
très grave pour un certain nombre de
personnes c'est à dire que tu as eu
beaucoup de gens à ces jeunes qui ont
fait des séjours très long arrêt à la
première vague même pendant un deuxième
vague ces journées là on met du temps à
s'en remettre ça peut être des semaines
voire des mois de rééducation après
avoir des conséquences quand on retrouve
et on se remet pas du tout et s'il est
vrai que le vario maintient la mortalité
à des niveaux plus bas que lors des
premières vagues les hospitalisations
elles ont grimpé en flèche récemment les
deux études qui ont été réalisées à la
fin du sud et en angleterre qui ont
montré que la sévérité de la mi temps et
finalement similaire à celle des
variants alpha et de luan des saintes à
tanger et les certes un peu plus faible
le delta mais et tout ça chez les
longues active donc c'est vraiment là
les personnes non immunisées chez eux le
ca retrouve 2 reste une manette cra si
au micro est aussi problématique que la
souche originel du virus comment alors
expliquer qu'il fait moins de dégâts
dans la population premièrement avec au
micro on a eu un changement radical
euros dans ses mains la vie c'est que
plutôt que de s'attaquer aux bronches le
belize va s'attaquer aux voies
respiratoires hautes c'est ce qui fait
qu'il ya moins deux autres explications
quand on est contaminé par le saas cloud
2 et donc on attrape le coc vide de
moins en moins de personnes pour qui
c'est un virus totalement nouveau et sur
lequel insistait le militaire va être
totalement démunis le fait qu'on ait
moins de décès et les moins
d'hospitalisations c'est parce que la
population et pianiste de plus en plus
que ce soit par l'interruption ou par le
vaccin c'est vrai qu'on va se diriger de
plus en plus ouvert une maladie on
espère plutôt endémique qui
ressemblerait peut-être à d'autres virus
respiratoires comme la gay mais à
l'heure actuelle
les personnes non vaccinées qu'elles
courent un risque beaucoup plus graves
avec l'omc rend qu'avec un virus de
grippe une fois de plus l approche des
beaux jours et davantage avec au micro
et les taux de vaccination très
importants en europe et
[Musique]
en trouver
on peut envisager pour le moyen terme et
long terme et si on dansait rien n'est
pas limpide apparition
une situation endémique c'est à dire un
virus qui circule dans dans la
population qui peine toujours à tuer des
gens je pars mais qui est maîtrisée qui
n'a pas paru bouleversé dans le système
de soins est aussi dans les courbes de
mortalité
aussi à la montagne au tout début
gouttelettes était complètement dingue
c'était aussi très grave les gens
mouraient très facilement et maintenant
que les personnes personne se sent et
didier qui mieux que les personnes
fragiles et coronavirus des cousins de
farce contre ceux qui sont responsables
de rhume on pense que ce sont
probablement les russes qui étaient
responsables allemands au séparant est
responsable il ya très longtemps au cp
et que au fur et à mesure avec
l'initiation de la population est devenu
un virus pandémique néanmoins c'est le
cela même s'il ne faisait rien n'est pas
du tout dangereux et bouquin d'une
banale il ya un peu parfois chez des
personnes âgées fragiles il peut donner
des formes sévères
[Musique]